last night I had a very uncomfortable
situation we're at the club yeah what
happened
hi I did that he's laughing right now I
already I it's gotta be in Santa I did
stand whatever I just hand up about yeah
Jeremiah I'm leaving I'm about to walk
out scot-free we had a great time go to
another spot everything's gonna be great
Laugh Factory and Emily at the store
goes hey do you want to a spot in the
main room Joey's on it burrs on it Greg
Fitzsimmons on it I was like hell yeah
of course and we're walking through the
main room and she goes yeah you know
it's um it's like it's a benefit for
people on the spectrum and I'm like hold
on there's [ __ ] people here like
what's good cuz I just don't I was like
I'll just pass I don't know exactly how
to do it you know and then she was no no
no it's like people in a halfway house
to me halfway house is you were you know
had some drugs you maybe we're in jail
locked up and they're trying to bring
the backyard right listen I usually say
drop my I go to drug addict we're drug
doesn't matter right so I go halfway
that's okay I'm walking in the back to
some guys with like beards like face
tattoos oh my god some rough guys are
trying to get the life back together and
I'm excited because I'm like these guys
aren't gonna be a finished [ __ ] I can't
[ __ ] go in [ __ ] yeah
I get brought up onstage I do a couple
jokes things are going really well and
then I go into this bit
there's [ __ ] Ben right can you see how
like wine is now multiplied Wyatt it is
now by like a thousand that's what that
full room felt like really it got real
quiet I'm like this is weird but you
were crushing before that cuz I saw you
early on it was good I'm not I'm not the
guy who like says Oh or killed every set
like I'm the most critical it was going
it was no well yeah it was going hard
took a little turn and then I would say
I got it back up to about like 50% right
that's a hard hole to dig out of it we
were artists we were TV shows I walk off
stage and Diaz goes uh he goes yes yes
hey uh why'd you closer to [ __ ] joke
it's a benefit for retouch yeah is for
[ __ ] [ __ ] it's okay kiddo
goes dude balls banded to that [ __ ]
joke and brothers that's I went pretty
well Jesus end bro I go back this is a
smaller part rank don't know it was were
just staring at it some people that had
a lot of time to get it right they've
had 20 years to get it right you know
you want a hole you know it holds up you
know it holds up after all this time
it's changed the way they shoot comedy
and sitcoms
hold on Malcolm in the Middle get out
get out get the [ __ ] out not weird
what's how that works out for sure how
many wise yes oh it's a TV show
god no no no that was a seminal young
watch that [ __ ] I know what I'm
talking about so what I thought you
would know oh it's a TV show
hold on it's a TV show and it's a comedy
Larry Sanders Oh
Garry Shandling yeah that holds up the
writing everything's funny you oh you'll
back watch some older stuff like right
yeah now coming out of a pisses I'm
gonna know it was a game-changer comedic
Lee actually and it came out the same
year my show came out and I was like I
watched that pilot and I watched our
pilot I went okay what show I'm on I'm
on a shitty show the show inside shorts
and I went i watch then I go oh well
that's the show
Todd home I just can't get into those
shows but outside Larry Sanders though
how dare you hmm shanlee I've never seen
Malcolm into I saw was that okay you
know what and I know that and I saw a
thing on the 2000 servers or the 90 you
watch some recap of it yeah yeah you
talk about how it was a seminar so but
of course that was my acting teacher the
ball guy right there that was math yeah
I just finished I just finished the
Garry Shandling's
book that Judd Apatow wrote yeah it's
just like his his uh his journals and
interviews and just what he's going
through when the shows coming through
it's pretty interesting such a go to
such a beast
such a good writer and so much a good
writer what I do yeah but his ability to
like you know see what's gonna work and
what doesn't so much of it is like when
you're around those guys they'll be like
now this is true this is too much but
it's really funny but what's what's
crazy with him and right is he was
supposed to replace Johnny car he hosted
for Johnny Carson a bunch then they're
gonna give him his own Tonight Show and
he had a it was to me at the time to
back in the day yet one's his 70s 80s it
was 2 million a year to host 5 nights a
week
yeah and he's just like I'm not gonna be
happy doing that how so he's like I want
to do a show making fun of that yes and
they were like I guess and was actually
on Showtime and so he wrote it based off
that where he could still check the box
from being a host of a Tonight Show but
it was like making fun of that and it
was pretty cool neat guy I met him a
couple of times he seems so [ __ ] sad
you met him later on yeah right
yeah he helps so many people did a
couple charity stand-up things with him
too and yeah I remember meet him at a
charity thing Kevin Nealon birthday
buddies with Whitney we went there and
it uh he's just excited towards the end
of the road for him they're pissed off
man well he died of a heart attack no he
actually was feeling some I think maybe
in the end it was a heart attack yeah
but he was feeling bad and called his
like a sister was like a if he had to go
to the hospital the guy's the guy can't
do it today I can take you tomorrow he's
like alright I'm fine I'll wait and then
the next day you got our tech in this
hour because we're following the peloton
controversy I got what can help you just
now notice them these no cuz my eyes
hurt hey Brendan what's up bro listen
I'm we're friends right
yeah I guess man I'm Eve replay through
the Al Pacino we can take off the lace
oh can you take off the lace shield they
talk about my my traps guys I gotta be
friends with you it's very difficult for
me men can you take off the lace shield
because no man they're so terrible I
can't do that for you you had to keep
Mon ha I got is that velcros that come
off with Velcro nope
so how does that work it's tight in
there bro you tied it in I didn't do and
you think that's what
you know got those socks too huh trove
Scouts didn't come with socks
nope no separate it
these are honey badger socks shut up to
Daniel Ricciardo we'll never really be
truly as close as we could be I can't do
we just don't see no I
we just don't see eye to eye and just
and you were looking at were you looking
at my socks my white socks but you have
that whole getup this just but that does
a terrible shoes right at least we know
that give that to me
oh those are terrible shoes you don't
know shoes no no I do know shoes because
I do it for fifty tears but but those
are terrible shoes we got rain boots on
yeah well that it's 90 degrees outside
on my rain but am i ringing yes black
the same thing every day
terrible shoes do you don't think I wish
I could dress like you're not give a
[ __ ] and just wake up with a same thing
do you have to be this big take this at
least take this lace shield off nope can
i all right let me just see one thing
nope don't try taking up these shoes can
zip them I want to see what I don't know
has to we all heard these ideas relax
just relax all right
what's laces do you just seen the laces
nice you leave it now so you guys leave
it open
some guys leave it open oh my god you're
so ridiculous at least admit you're
ridiculous right I mean these some
pretty ridiculous shoes man traps got
customs tough to get now if you had to
sell those on the black market breast
thousand get a grand pharma paid 200 for
them you know they say art and expensive
watches hold their value very expensive
watches papa
well now you're [ __ ] do it cuz your
dumb ass on zip though yeah
all right sorry I unzipped your lace
shield that's all right man can I wish I
could just wake up and go I'm gonna wear
this I dressed like a normal man I mean
I mean zero effort no I dressed for
comfort
yeah I know but we're just different
dude you're older you don't know what
the [ __ ] it is they just see billboards
so I think all those people like oh this
is awesome
and then all these people that are
taking care of a [ __ ] at home are like
what the [ __ ] is going on I'm supported
sued the first comic that went on I
think was like mentally challenged but I
didn't know I thought he was just a
comic because you know comics registry
you know comic can be awkward a little
bit yes yes yes yes I just thought he
was awkward and um I think I came talk
about our interaction but uh I felt so
[ __ ] bad yeah I felt so fun you were
too laughs factor after that I went to
laugh after that yeah honestly the
audience was more [ __ ] not you two
of them expected that one you know I
walked in Jose okay close eyes here do
you guys wear those fitbit's at all I
don't wear that [ __ ] well whoo a thing
about the another thing with whoo it's
our thing you guys did for your
competition right I don't have a
competition that was the free time I'm
sober October no didn't you guys feel
like a weight loss thing I did that this
is real this connection really happened
to I'm sure a lot of people [ __ ] how do
we know it just wasn't Jack and I'll say
it say it say that's a text message I'm
not text message set it up well we got
each other Fitbit stuff right and then
you're tracking their fitness levels it
was fun gift for each other and then
later on she found out at 4:00 a.m. his
heartbeat was going what crazy yeah and
she wasn't going to exercise or anything
else and it's at 4:00 a.m. she knew she
knew she knew yeah she know she's
walking to me Warren
get it hard he creates it jackin it
that's why I yeah you got yeah you got
to have sex on on your back man so
you're going around you if you cheat
your arms gotta be right next to you why
did you leave them around do people wear
them all yes you try you go online and
check how your spouse no no you leave
them on all the time I thought you know
when you work out right because it'll
track your sleep yeah that's the main
reason people work for me that for me
it'd be like what are you doing it for
him your hearts body I do I'm having a
panic attack I'm freaking but yet I
think about the world think about what I
got to do this week yeah that's really
me I wake up at 6 a.m. like girl I foggy
dude I sleep like [ __ ] I can't turn off
the head this guy could have got out of
it yeah but what nah nah nah he probably
he probably wanted her to catch him
she's pretty hot who is the girl oh let
me see I see
oh yeah why would I give that to you as
a gift it's a gift